I think it's really gonna be dependent
on the kinds of choices people make I
you know I suppose I would be I'd be
more optimistic if I felt other people
were less irrationally optimistic I
think people are not fully aware of some
of the risks and some of the challenges
we face and because of that are overly
complacent and I think that's that seems
to me is a recipe for dramatically
increasing the probability something
very bad bad happening but but you know
these things are very it's very hard to
it's very hard to know and you know it's
very hard to know which choices are
going to be the critical ones and how
these things are precisely and work out
because the world's a big place a lot of
complicated things are going on I tend
to I guess my if I had a if I had to
make a if you held a gun to my head and
forced me to make a prediction I think
we're headed towards you know 20 30
years of incredible chaos and turmoil
and then at the tail end of who will
emerge with a world better than any weak